now you mentioned large cats
let me be in delicate how large are we
talking
i mean i mean they're like 20 pounds
jesus
wait 20 pounds like if they're wearing
flemish armor or 20 pounds soaking wet
uh
both
soaking wet i guess i mean you're saying
just 20 pounds each
yeah yeah are we very large are we
allowed to fat shame a cat yes i think
so i think so too thank you i
i i would never that doesn't sound very
into it well sona i just don't know how
you're gonna do it oh what do you do you
want me i can go get him i'll hold him
up we can i want to see this cat yeah at
some point but i don't want you to put
your pull your back out lifting this
you know
uh probably not too hard to catch
just put some roast beef on a string
oh my god
jesus look at that
oh my god that's odin what are you
missing
how many how many hams a day does he eat
i'm sure more than he that i give him
are they finicky eaters what a massive
cat no no they love uh they love treats
i give them uh they love string cheese
actually right but these cats look like
they eat large sandwiches you know what
i mean like they're not they're not
nibbling yeah they're not nibbling on
kibble they're they look up at you if
you put a little fish in their bowl
they're like
and then you go oh sorry and then they
put a giant [ __ ] blt in their bowl
and they're like
and then they
eat it that's the thing they're just
constantly hungry we're just constantly
feeding them treats
and things that we're eating ice cream
they love ice cream and tuna
well who doesn't love ice cream okay so
uh these cats um did you know they were
going to be heavy cats when you got them
as kittens
yeah yeah yeah we knew that we were
getting a large breed uh so they're
siberians
and uh we actually got them because my
husband is hypo or is allergic
to cats and these are they have less
allergens in their fur
um so we had to go and do a whole like
allergy test at the
uh breeders house lenia before we got
them
your husband your life partner let's
give him a name let's give him a name
brian brian brian you
you uh stood stood up and and promised
to love and cherish him for all time he
has one
one weakness which is he's allergic to
cats
yes you you went out and bought two
20-pound cats
i sure did we just like went all in
i know it's a huge cat or nothing
right and guess what's the right choice
between those two nothing
i mean when you held up that cat odin he
looked ashamed he knows oh he did coney
you don't think he goes online and looks
at
svelt cats online and and has image you
know sort of uh i mean we all do things
like that you know you look at stealth
games no unless i go on i go online and
i look at like really thin comedians and
i'm like oh look you're so thin
you know not like old chunky here and i
i get way in my head about it and i'm
sure your cats are doing that too i oh
man
that's a big cat you were you feel sorry
for them but then you asked if you could
fat shame them so i don't i don't know
what side you're on right i was faking
feeling sorry for them that's what i
thought okay that makes that's on brand
yeah it felt like i should just sort of
throw that out there like oh you know
that must be tough for them but um
really those are just massive massive
cats
uh and
that's unbelievable but um you know it
makes sense i guess the siberian you
think about it and i like to think about
things
it's siberia it's very cold
one of the coldest uh habitats on earth
it's cheap very cold and so these cats
have to be
uh covered in fat in order to survive
and yeah um
so you live in wisconsin so you know
yeah gotta they gotta do what they to do
uh during the summer do you ever shave
them just down to the skin and let them
sit in chairs and near the pool
you know we haven't but that's that's a
great idea i do have to brush them a lot
though because they get
there's a lot of fur on them
yeah well you could probably uh you know
sell that on etsy
um yeah should just like give them a
drink put them in a chair
yeah they would chip ice cream you know
i would think so yeah um well i think uh
man uh the the cats are a um uh
i'm sorry the cats are
are
they're bloated but i wish them the best